boys welcome back to the channel as you
guys know been investing millions of
dollars into the studio
but i got a camera i don't know how to
really operate
and i pressed the wrong button i just
want to show you guys this
i screwed up the white balance okay look
at me
there look how tan i was and then now
somehow i messed i'm gonna figure it out
my half cube inside when i
turned this setting on left the building
okay and the white
the whiteness that i have in my running
through my veins hostile takeover but
anyway i'll be trying to get that
somewhere in that look back and look
it's not that i'm vain
i just don't want to be accused of
identity theft look there's already one
too many of these uh
pale half cuban boys with beards named
steven on the internet you know what i
mean
like that's not that's that's not us our
name is not stephen bonnell so
anyway that's my point so this is my
official announcement
it's my camera it's the million dollar
setup it's it's screwed up right now i'm
gonna fix it
but in the meantime i had a professor
who just was arrested for secretly
working for china
and that's i mean that's it that's
that's the headline and it's absolutely
true
check this out this is so blow your mind
so somebody sent me this as you guys
know
i went to texas a m hold your applause
please don't apply
no stop it stop it no no
no no no stop it stop it stop it stop it
stop it stop it stop it stop it stop it
okay keep going keep going
i know i know it's kind of a big deal
okay i went to texas a m
anyways i saw this little article
in the battalion and it's a texas a m
professor arrested
accused of lying about chinese
affiliations while working with nasa
and so i see this guy i'm like oh it's
just probably some guy that i don't know
and then i'm like
zooming in and i'm like wait that guy
looks familiar
and then i thought i mean it's been a
while since i've been in college it's
been a few years now
but i was like did i take that professor
i feel like i had that professor before
i could swear i had him
so i looked him up zheng dong chang
or uh dr chang as we knew him
and sure enough like i'm bad with names
but i remembered this guy
i was like something about this guy i
know i had him before
check this out dude ladies and gentlemen
i logged back into my old account
and looked back in 2015
and yes i took him i had a safety course
a safety engineering course and i had
zhang chang in monday wednesday friday
in the blocker room which was a building
on campus
now what does that mean guys am i
qualified to speak about whether zheng
chang's
worked for china or not i think so
in fact i think i have incriminating
circumstantial evidence to add
if the doj wants to to call me you know
i'm ready to takashi 69 this guy
because when you go look at the court
order he had been committing this uh
these actions from april 2013 until
present which means
at the time i was taking his course he
was
fraudulently uh working for china
while also working for america and per
maybe
allegedly maybe stealing trade secrets
from american companies now
i want to talk about my experience with
them because i kind of feel bad
because frankly this guy was a
great professor well by great professor
i mean that i got an a in his course
dude i was not the perfect student as
you can tell
but i got an a in that guy's course and
the one thing i remember about it
is that i never went to that class at
the beginning of every year in college
you try to determine which of these
classes do i actually have to attend
and which ones can i just study right
before the test
this was definitely a study right before
the test and i thought at the time
huh that's weird a lot of these
professors were like you had to show up
consistently
but now it makes sense because i think
this guy was too busy working for china
to really to really run the class and
it's not just me saying that like just
look at the criminal complaint
it says that during about nine months he
spent approximately 133 days
outside of the united states so
he is going back and forth between china
and the unit us all the time so
how are his students gonna show up he
doesn't even want him to show up because
he's not gonna be there
but it's hard for me to hate on him too
much because at the time and still now i
was like when you're trying to keep your
gpa up
i mean it's pretty nice to get an a for
barely showing up at all
so i don't know i'm conflicted about
this one i really
am because i liked zheng dang chang
i really did and now it turns out he
may have been a chinese spy and i uh
i don't know really how to feel about it
because on the one hand i want him to
get
acquitted on the other hand
he definitely lied he was very sneaky
apparently my professor was trying to
become something called a
ttp recipient it's called the chinese
talent program but
allegedly it's just a way that they pay
scientists who work in america
um and they get them to steal ip
i mean that's definitely simplifying it
but
that's basically what this thing alleges
so it's kind of a big deal that this guy
was working
for nasa he got this almost million
dollar grant with nasa which he was the
principal investigator on
and he was constantly certifying
throughout that process that he has no
affiliations with china because he's
going to get this u.s grant to work on
u.s technology
and he conveniently forgets to mention
that he had a chinese technology company
that he formed
oh and he conveniently forgets to
mention that he filed two
chinese patents while he's working for
nasa based on similar research i mean
you can't make this stuff up dude
he's double dipping hard not a good look
for texas a m
and definitely not a good look for my
professor here i don't know
i mean on the one hand how do you guys
feel having a professor that gives you
a's for basically doing nothing on the
other hand your professor is
working for the chinese government while
getting nasa grants and potentially
handing over ip and it's not just zheng
dog chang
who's uh you know who's tied to china
it's a bunch of these guys
look at this this is a former cleveland
clinic researcher charged with fraud for
failing to disclose china ties so it's
the same thing
look at this guy acclaimed harvard
scientist is arrested accused of lying
about ties to china
it's an epidemic i found this uh paper
in science mag
four years after the national institutes
of health began to investigate grantees
who had believed it failed to disclose
their ties to foreign governments
officials still don't know the extent of
the problem
we learned of 150 cases in the last 12
months
so this is uh extremely bad
and this was a very sneaky thing for
sangdong chain to do
and i'm disappointed in him as a former
student of his but what i'm most
interested in is to see what china's
response to this is whether they're
gonna try to
get him back to the country or or what i
mean
i don't know we'll see anyway that's it
let me know what you think in the
comments below
and thanks for watching and don't forget
to smash like
and subscribe thank you
[Music]
us
comes along